[موسيقى]
أنا أقف على شكل مثلث مرحبًا بكم في
مدينتي باكو أذربيجان قد لا
يتوقعها الناس ولكن باكو مدينة مجنونة
بكرة القدم يشاهد الناس كرة القدم هنا كل أسبوع
يلعب الأطفال كرة القدم في
كل مكان في الملاعب الثقافية والحفلة
حسنًا ، نحن آمو أحد الشخصيات البارزة
لاعبين إقليميين آخرين لكرة القدم ،
كان باهاما مساعدًا مساعدًا في نهائي كأس العالم 1966
بين إنجلترا وألمانيا ،
فقراره منح هدف لإنجلترا
جعلهم أبطال العالم لأول
مرة في تاريخهم ، وسمي هذا الملعب
باسمه هنا نحن في
أكبر  الملعب الجديد في
أذربيجان سيستضيف ملعب باكو الأولمبي
نهائي الدوري الأوروبي 2019
سيلعب مايك في تشيلسي هنا ضد
آرسنال ، وأنا متحمس جدًا لمشاهدة
طائرة تشيلسي في هذا الخطاب في اليوم الأخير
[موسيقى]